morning Millennials welcome back to the
morning toast happy Thursday that feels
like a Friday cuz it is our last show of
the week before the holiday weekend but
I digress it is in fact a Thursday the
day after hump day which is always a sad
day because you can't hump anything
anymore
it is a Thursday that feels like a
Friday so I'm just gonna go with Friday
but yeah definitely so excited for the
holiday weekend so excited to be doing a
show with you oh that is so sweet says
so much to be so excited about it before
we say anything else I need to clear
something up that Dina Manzo and
Caroline Manzo are sisters who married
brothers so it was very much like the
dear toaster set we had yesterday only I
had realized the connection all of the
connection so so many people let us know
I mean some pocket of my brain must have
known that because we did watch the
early seasons of Real Housewives of New
Jersey no and even when we came to the
resolution that we came to yesterday it
did it make sense right they've always
been sisters but then in that article it
was like they married brother and so if
the whole thing didn't make sense to me
but now understanding that they are
sisters who did in fact marry brothers I
appreciate all the responses and
actually actually also got a lot of
responses from people just about the
whole Tati Shane take because everybody
has such an interesting take on it and I
love hearing from people and honestly
from them for the most part what I got
from people is like at the end of the
day it doesn't even matter because you
just can't be on Shane's side because
he's so awful and what and it's true
like what his videos and I told you I'm
now on the tic-tock side of youtube
drama
and they've been resurfacing some of his
old videos and they're just they're just
awful like they're they're unforgivable
so you just have to take two Tati side
because you can't take Chainz so what
you're saying is we're if you could just
take Shane out of the equation for a
second like but people still aren't on
Totti side like you can't but you know
what's so interesting is like I feel
like the community's not on any one side
like they're literally like breaking
down talk to use video like pointing out
the inconsistencies they're cancelling
chain and they're waiting for Geoffrey
to do something so they can jump on it
got it okay well I feel like the
community I mean at least between us
like it feels like most people are just
bothered to have had their time wasted
which is so crazy because like I have
nothing but time to waste these days I
didn't
that honestly that thought never even
occurred to me I was like grateful for
the content no and you know what I'm
grateful for like I think what Tati did
to James Charles initially and then when
James like came back I think that was
such an interesting like social
experiment I agree in the way that
people just hop on these bandwagons
without having all information no and
they only hop on the bandwagon because
like all of their friends are doing it
like they don't actually build even this
got all of totty they just like are
doing it because everyone else is I feel
like I don't have friends who watch
Itachi's video I watched sure I'm not
talking about you I'm like who's this
sweet woman this is so sad no I think a
lot of people within the beauty
community like saw the numbers like
everyone was now subscribing she talked
to you so they just like go with it
because that's what everyone's doing and
it's easier to just do what the world is
doing than like try and form your own
opinion sometimes no I think it's easier
to just take what's right in front of
you instead instead of seeking out
additional information that - but I also
like we don't have we didn't have the
additional information until James spoke
but I just I always reference that
controversy controversy because I think
it was just so interesting and the in
the whims of the public I totally agree
the whims of the puppet was a
sociological experiment and what was
interesting was that like Tati also
thought that was associate this whole
thing was a joke and they were filming
it and then remember she said that under
video that like this will have been some
big social experiment that she was like
the butt of the joke which is just
somebody that she also thought that yeah
well she thought that after the fact is
like it was so crazy her when like she
wasn't even the one with the real issue
whatever I think we spent so much time
talking about it yesterday without any
additional information I have nothing
else to say no but I really could like
go on with people about it forever
because I like I agree with what
everyone's saying like no one's saying
anything wrong like it is done that
we're talking about this again like talk
to you honestly it's a little too
convenient for her to be just like
blaming it all on her being gas-lit all
but Shane and Jeffrey are like very
problematic I don't know I agree with
everyone great that's what we like to do
here at the tips but today's show is
gonna be fabulous of course Fast Five
stories I hear a rumor it's unfounded so
I can't confirm or deny at this moment
but I did hear a rumor that there is a
Kelly's mindless news happening today
which I mean it makes sense because
we're heading into 4th of July weekend
and so there would have to be Kelly's -
news like the 4th of July
holy [ __ ] this day Kelly's mindless news
like that fourth of July wow I didn't
even realize the the important
historical moment that is currently
happening or this weekend what kind of
importance this weekend held for not
only our country but Kelly Kelly Ripa as
well her ki men Wow fabulous
um so should we just dive right in I
think we jump right in
you know what I really have oh I do have
something to say oh so do I a new
episode of the redheads just dropped
this morning recapping I Know Why the
Caged Bird Sings by Maya Angelou we were
all so moved by this book so we have so
much to say about it and I hope you read
along with us and listen to the episode
let us know what you thought about the
book we love a lively discussion love
Dana assign the next book which looks so
interesting okay so we just love that
some variety that's fabulous everyone
check it out available on Spotify and
iTunes and while you're there on iTunes
you could just meander to over to the
movie section and order my special
disgraced queen my debut comedy special
it is just still in the charts it's on
the homepage of iTunes and I am so
grateful that I just I can't even
literally I see people in the street I
like to take their phone and order it
like I just am out of control so you are
no exception you can order it on Amazon
Prime you can order it on iTunes ton of
other platforms head over my Instagram
stories for more details if you're
looking for links and people who are
international Amazon and iTunes are your
best bet because they have the most
countries you know what else is crazy
well that it's July
yesterday was diverse and I had like no
concept of it and I have to apologize to
our Canadian toasters for not
recognizing Canada today yesterday that
that's our bad happy Canada Day
no no that's on me happy Canada Day
happy kind of today guys how does the
song go beautiful
[Music]
Tellem says we see this the tumor strong
and free
hey hey we stand on guard for thee for
me really good sick and handsome I could
put a remix on it you can find me in the
club again and in school they taught us
it half French and half English I must
have missed that day yes
so that sign of the first half in French
and the second half of the half that I
knew in English a beautiful song happy
Canada Day tour Canadian toaster yes you
feel free to play this on public
television all over Canada so should we
do you think yeah I think we should just
jump okay there's no time like the
present ever period point blank so let's
get right into the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast and that's true and I'm so proud
and excited to be highlighting since it
is our last show of the week we are
going to be highlighting another
fabulous black owned business and
today's is called beneath your mask
indulgence is born from necessity
beneath your mask was created to reverse
the toxic effects of environmental
hazards health challenges stress and
other unforgiving aspects of our
lifestyles on a quest to nourish
revitalize and heal the damage done to
her skin and hair from a lupus diagnosis
the founder of beneath your mask Dana
began crafting non-toxic beauty that
doesn't compromise on any level beauty
that is safe to absorb and doesn't
challenge the immune system their
collection is handcrafted with love for
those that not only appreciate indulging
but are also extremely concerned with
the ingredients used in their beauty
ritual beneath your mask source the
world's most potent organic and wild
harvested botanicals from 25 countries
each chosen for its healing and
restorative properties the entire site
is on pre-order now due to the
overwhelming response and recent press
from the last two weeks but restocks are
coming quickly some of their most
popular products are the heel whipped
skin souffle an ultra luxurious
incredibly nourishing whipped skin
souffle contains antibacterial
anti-aging and antioxidant properties
and has been formulated to hydrate and
strengthen skin another really popular
product is
remedy conditioning lip balm an all-day
all-night lip treatment that can nourish
and repair the delicate skin on your
lips though it's packed with many potent
oils including Moringa babassu cacao and
Shea its star ingredient in skin
protecting zoomy Nia an African plum oil
that is rich as it is rare dana has
birthed a brand that o not only tackles
the misconceptions that organic natural
and healing cannot feel luxurious and
chic but also where a commitment to
health and wellness meets a lifestyle of
exquisite beauty decadence so the
products are fabulous the packaging is
chic rich but it's all organic it's also
good for you again a lot of the products
are on pre-order because they're blowing
up but the restocks are coming really
quickly so to learn more about beneath
your mask and to place a pre-order today
visit beneath your mask dot-com and
nourish revitalize and transform your
skin and hair with pure non-toxic Beauty
that appeals to all your senses thank
you beneath your mask for letting us
highlight you today posters show some
more things that look I literally feel
like just in reading that copy I took a
trip to the spot like your skin cleared
up so relaxed no totally okay we have
some great stories for you today first
story a little breaking news the Justice
Department see well I don't know about
the DOJ the DOJ it's like in the
category of trust you know it's the
Justice Department also known as the
Department of Justice cuisine Maxwell
has been arrested by FBI on charges
relating to Jeffrey Epstein
fuck-you glissade Maxwell you are just
as guilty if not more than Jeffrey
Epstein because those girls trusted you
and you're a monster and I hate you and
I hope you rotten in a prison cell for
the rest of your life and why did it
take so long they couldn't find her
yeah members someone thought they saw
her at in and out but it was like a
prank yeah close a Maxwell the British
socialite and close friend of sex
offender Jeffrey Epstein has been
arrested by the FBI NBC News has
reported quote she was arrested on the
East Coast on obscene related charges
and is expected to appear in a federal
court later today the report says oh so
soon Maxwell had kept a low profile and
her whereabouts were unknown since
Epstein's arrest last July on charges
that he abused and trafficked in women
and girls in Manhattan in Florida
between 2002 to 2005 I mean like more
than that but yeah
yeah well then he went to his Island he
took it to the island all right which is
not on US jurisdiction as I should know
that if I work for the DOJ but the FBI
did rate it so but it was harder to
catch him on the island well I just
think this is fabulous long overdue I'm
doing like a little dance knowing that
glues a Maxwell is a terrible person who
was an aider and abettor of an enormous
sexual predator and now she's gonna
probably hopefully God willing brush em
spend the rest of her life in prison
right so hopefully a little justice will
be served
I just hope she did step one of justice
I just hope she too doesn't mysteriously
disappear in the night you know there's
so much creepy vibes like in this whole
situation like so much Illuminati like
what's really going on and it's very
possible she could you know like escape
yeah definitely because she's every
switch on her own every time this story
like you think it can't get crazier it
goes and gets crazier yeah and look
she's super connected through obviously
like Jeffrey and like the network of
pedophiles that she procured and who
they protect yes but she's also very
wealthy on her own the documentary
explained it a little bit like her dad
is like a British publishing magnate or
something yes but then it was
questionable and his death was very
spooky on a boat related to perhaps
money troubles interesting yes so it's
all quite spooky yes Glee's Ain I don't
like you know what how do you pronounce
her name cause England's aim kill aim is
what they said yeah that's what they
said in the documentary but I don't want
to give her the respect of pronouncing
her name correctly so glaze Ain whatever
your name is
bye that's what that's what they said in
the documentary and it was like such a
fabulous like claim I'm like no it's
glaze Lane
[ __ ] Lane no I'm Wayne I'm like she
made me so mad in the documentary
arguably more than Jeffrey Epstein
because yeah because she was just as bad
she participated in the abuse yeah look
she abused a lot of girls it wasn't
really touched upon I'm actually a lot
of problems with the documentary we
spoke about in a few episodes ago but I
just feel like it wasn't enough like for
parts like when we got an eight-part
tiger King and like a reunion special
like and we're still hearing from him
from prison like I could have used
literally a ten-part Geoffrey I've seen
I feel like it went so much deeper into
more celebrities more businessmen more
politicians but they just really kept it
to Jeffrey and barely to gali
so um I would like a redo actually oh
interesting
I still didn't finish it I need like a
real Netflix does good documentaries but
this was done by Netflix and honestly I
was really disappointed I need like a
invent a Discovery Channel what does
that ID I oh whatever
and then investigation investigation
discovery the place that does Forensic
Files like I wanted them to put together
especially for me maybe maybe you'll get
that I feel like especially as this
story develops you know with Gillian and
who knows what what comes next it would
always be possibilities for more
documentaries I just feel like and also
when one documentary is made about a
topic five more come out there is no
statistically speaking so you have five
coming your way I just feel like it's
important that we never stop talking
about Jeffrey Epstein because at the end
of the day there are so many people who
are still free people I don't know their
names yet but I know that there's like
celebrities politicians businessmen
important people world leaders who were
a part of the Ring and I know they want
this to go away but I will not let it go
away yeah because you want to know why
Jeffrey Epstein did not kill himself and
I think that's important that everyone
talked about it every day when you're
saying your morning prayers you get on
your knees you cross your heart you say
and remember Jeffrey Epstein did not
kill himself yeah but you know what I
think the good news is that we are all
really on the same page about that
matter how many times this article would
like to say Epstein who pleaded not
guilty killed himself in his Manhattan
jail cell in August I'm sorry The
Guardian did no one tell you that
Jeffrey Epstein didn't kill himself
you you're real silly okay you know the
Guardian like whoever wrote that like
yeah and you know what actually gives me
solace like peace of mind is that you
know our country is so divided right now
and like the the political climate it's
just really toxic like I feel like
people are just have never been
disagreeing more but at the end of the
day we can all sit down for dinner and
agree that Jeffrey Epstein did not kill
himself and you know what if that's what
Jeffrey Epstein brought to that world
and that's his legacy it's kind of
powerful yeah that's actually not his
legacy his legacy is be my sexual
offender but I agree with you Claudia
that's beautiful idiot that's agreeable
okay ready for our next story because
it's up it's the news that I know you
didn't ask for but it still warms my
heart okay Khloe Kardashian and Tristan
Thompson are giving their relationship
another
try it's so weird I absolutely love
Khloe Kardashian like I'm arguably not
one of her biggest fans but when it
comes to reporting on stories about her
love life like I'm immediately heading
to China bill yeah well I this is my
stop at China station really not smoking
about these two because they're so
uninteresting
yeah and it's always like news that's
not really news and just about them
co-parenting and forgiveness etc but it
seems as though they really are getting
back together and I shape I'm gonna go
ahead and say it I should well I [ __ ]
because I have a child and I think if
they can work it out that would be great
for true do I think this is the greatest
love story of our generation absolutely
not do I think that it's gonna work out
for her most likely not do I believe in
trust that this is the best decision for
her well I trust her and it's her life
to make her own choices but you know
when you just like get that feeling like
I was actually thinking about Khloe
Kardashian yesterday because I was
looking well I was like stalking
pictures of Megan FAL Megan Fox and
Machine Gun Kelly I always call them
Megan Kelly okay Machine Gun Kelly and
Megan Fox but Derek celebrity name is
Megan Kelly and I was just looking at
pictures of them and like the way we
spoke about that I was like you just
know like I feel like they are gonna be
it forever and sometimes people get with
a partner and you just know that it's
like the end of the road for them we
were talking about someone this week
Billie lourd yes and so I haven't never
felt that way about Chloe because she
has such poor taste in man no I felt
that way about Lamar Oh about Lamar yeah
yeah but that didn't work out yeah I
just I just I don't not getting that
feeling I'm not I'm not feeling that at
all right now and so that's just kind of
my barometer for whether or not this is
gonna work out yeah but I do also feel
like sometimes I get that feeling about
a couple and then it's just nothing of
the sort
like who uh I don't know who's broken up
recently that was a shock like Ariana
and Pete you know but see their seeds
that's exactly that's think I'm so glad
you brought that up because sometimes
that feeling you have to be able to
identify that feeling within you is it
like the infatuation feeling where like
you're obsessed with like the the
pictures which honestly it might be for
me and megyn kelly but or are you
obsessed with like the future for them
like you have to really be able to be
introspective enough to identify that
feeling okay I have a couple that I want
to ask you about because they're really
going the distance and as far as like
and Priyanka no but yes them too yeah um
Justin Halley oh I'm I'm on the ship and
it's heading out to sea like its I am
happy for them I think they're actually
like dropping anchor to ya know I
believe in their love and I think for a
while it was just all so weird and fast
when like he was still being so linked
to Selena but at the end of the day like
what's going on the tabloid it's like
most likely it's not even going on in
real life it's irrelevant so it seemed
weird and fast and like she was like a
similar girl to Selena
but after learning about them I watch
actually a lot of his documentary I
definitely believe in their love they've
like the shared faith and I I believe in
their love person yeah I agree
okay well and it really worked out for
them both career-wise I just also feel
like when we ship when we build a ship
and we hop on and we got out to sea like
we were in oh no I I think the opposite
actually maybe we do are we cursed no I
think like when we all give a couple our
support like they feel supported
yeah therefore I am throwing my support
behind Chloe interest in okay no I am
too because I support her but like in
the back of my mind I'm just like being
realistic and that's you you really
can't blame me for that okay that's fine
that's fine okay
time will tell okay Garcelle from Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills says she
quote felt pressure as the first black
star of Real Housewives of Beverly Hills
big shoes to fill Garcelle is opening up
about being the first black cast member
of the Real Housewives of Beverly Hills
the actress who joined season ten and is
the first black woman to hold a diamond
since the franchise debuted in 2010
explained during a recent episode of the
reality life with Kate Casey podcast
that she felt quote pressure taking on
the role quote did I feel pressure of
being the first black woman on Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills yes I
definitely felt pressure that people
wanted me to come in and do a certain
thing or have a chip on my shoulder I
really didn't want to be labeled an
angry black woman she said of the
stereotype that's not who I am
I just wanted to stay true to who I am
and I think that's what people have been
able to see so far
definitely she also talked about
handling responses from social media she
said I was not prepared for how social
media takes over Lisa Rinna told me that
is one thing to shoot the show it's
another to see it and what the others
have said about you then the whole world
weighs in there are so many layers to
being on the show well I just I can't
stress enough
like how much of a disgrace it is that
it took ten seasons to at a black
housewife in Beverly Hills but now it
happened so great but it's a shame that
it took so long and I think our cell is
the perfect choice I think she's doing a
fabulous job and I love that she's being
open about like the experience about
like not wanting to be like put in a box
or labeled a certain way and I feel like
she's really coming in like I see her
it's like a very strong mom a strong
businesswoman a good friend funny
beautiful stylish I feel like she's
really grabbing all the elements like
she's doing it all yes using it all she
has opinions like I agree with so far
her two best men of every character so
far even though she's just meeting them
right we've known them for so long I'm
like nope you just summed it up really
well that's the key to a very good
housewife is like when they come on the
scene like what do they think of other
people that's why I immediately loved
Erika Jaynes sniper from the side that's
exactly who Lisa Vanderpump was and she
really encapsulated very well so if I
agree with like your take on things I'm
automatically a fan of yours yeah it's
just like with your judgment
mhmmm others yeah yeah I totally agree
I actually this article made me miss
housewives it's been like a long time
it's back this week I think next week
whatever yeah it's been so long it's
been so long I even miss Real Housewives
of you know I miss it too especially
because I feel like I keep seeing news
about Lea Ramona and now I miss the
girls yeah I miss my girls so I'm
excited for it to come back I'm excited
to recap it but I actually enjoyed the
break I feel like I got a lot done
during the break and it gave us I'd like
to want something to desire it like
absence makes the heart grow fonder so I
think that was actually like a Brit like
they're playing hard to get yeah Bravo
inadvertently yeah they are and it's
working for me
fabulously fabulously um may I just take
the floor for a moment of course
beautiful thank you so much because I'm
in my stomach kind of hurts I think my
RDH is actually I know yeah yeah I want
to take stamps calm for all of our sakes
we need to avoid crowds and ship same
thing do we need to avoid any crowds we
can right now but what if you need to
get to the post office what if you need
postage to send out letters and packages
well don't worry stamps comm is here to
help with stamps calm you can print
postage on demand and skip those lines
and crowds at the post office
Plus and you can actually save some
money with discount so you can't even
get at the post office
and if that wasn't enough stamps calm
also offers UPS services with discounts
up to 62% and no UPS residential
surcharges stamps.com brings all the
services of the US Postal Service right
to your computer in the safety and
comfort of your own home office or
anywhere else whether you're a small
business sending invoices and online
sellers shipping out products or you're
just working from home and need to mail
stuff stamps.com can handle it all with
ease simply use any computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail and send
it anywhere once your mail is ready you
just leave it for your mail carrier
schedule a free package pickup or drop
it in the mailbox no human contact is
required it is that simple and like we
said with stamps comm you get great
discounts to 5 cents off every
first-class stamp and up to 62 percent
off shipping rates stamps calm is a
no-brainer
especially now saving you time and money
and keeping you safe in these crazy
times
right now our listeners can get a
special offer that includes a four week
free trial plus free postage and a
digital scale without any long-term
commitment just go to stamps com click
on the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in toast
that's stamps comm click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in toast for a four-week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale
without any long-term commitment stay
safe you guys and go to stamps calm
enter code toast for a four-week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale
without any long-term commitment I'm so
sorry to a bother I love stamps I can't
I just want to say me to you and you
know when I was in intern actually at
the internship that like launched my
career which is where I know it's like
everyone's heard the story a million
times my job was like sending stuff out
and that's where I first started using
stamps calm and like it really even for
an intern like me it was super easy like
you just printed it and then you just
like put it on and then the guy came
like it was genius that's amazing I
thought they were like my job was gonna
make me keep walking back and forth with
all these boxes to the post office and I
was ready to quit on the spot but it was
a stamps.com oh man yes love it okay
next story producers respond to rumors
that the Ellen DeGeneres Show will be
canceled
well can you give a little background on
why people think that it got cancelled
yes the background information that I
have is from my sister Claudia and my
job which is that obviously there's been
like stuff going on with Ellen during
quarantine in terms of you know things
coming out
about her that she's rude and mean and
accordingly the meanest woman alive
that's what people allegedly but also
something strange was that she'd stopped
filming her show from home and then on
IMDB it said that her episode her last
episode was her final episode maybe that
meant season finale
according to Claudius according to
snitch it felt like a series finale so
there was just rumors swirl and I think
that like you know part of like this
room are getting so popular is that like
I think a lot of people want it to be
her last episode so it's like we're just
praying and like we're hoping that this
is true but what did they say okay
producers are speaking out rumors have
been swirling that Ellen might have had
her last dance insiders are whispering
that The Ellen Show could be cancelled
soon amid reports of falling ratings and
allegations of DeGeneres being quote
rude to the staff
however when reached by the post for
comment about the claims DeGeneres's
production company rep said Telepictures
can confirm it's untrue see to be honest
I don't really like Ellen but I feel
like this would be a terrible way to go
out like yeah in the midst of all this
controversy like you're just gonna bow
out and I feel very weird about Ellen
because like yeah she's the meanest
woman alive Blake is that a crime no
like obviously she's not like the
greatest person to work with but she's
like a very accomplished lgbtq+ icon and
it would be sad if like this is how she
went out yeah I feel - I feel so weird
about her like I literally hate her but
like I don't feel like she deserves to
be connects her yeah I respect her and I
don't feel like she should be cancelled
like stripped of her success yeah
because she's like sometimes a bit I
mean
people should treat others with kind of
green there's also the chance that you
know some of these rumors are unfounded
and maybe she's not as sad as people
think says she is and so I think if
that's the case then she should just
continue doing what she does and
spreading light and kindness on her show
well the irony is like not lost on us
that her whole vibe on the show was a
kindness giving back philanthropy and it
turns out like behind the scenes she's
like this evil woman if she is you know
rumors we haven't heard from her on the
matter and so I just think the proof is
in the pudding and so if she wants to
bow out now it would kind of confirm
everything that we heard yeah and it
would just be like a sad way to go out
for what is like a very successful and
accomplished career yeah
don't think it's over mean I think that
like filming from home has been weird
for everyone and everyone's on break now
Jimmy Kimmel and there's just sort of up
in the air with next plans yeah so I
don't know but part of me is like let's
say it's true what's she's mean she's
mean like okay like of course we should
be nice to others but like doesn't make
you a criminal like yeah and it doesn't
mean you should be canceled like I just
feel like the way people come for Ellen
and myself included like I don't like
her but like the way she's like the butt
of every joke and like on Twitter people
really come for it's just like weird
when like really all she did was like be
nasty which of course isn't good you
should always be kind to others but in
the grand scheme of the world of like
people who have gotten cancelled it's
really like a 2 out of 10 yeah I agree
so just something to think about I agree
something you should think about this
and of course be kind to others like
it's not cool no matter how much just
successful you are like you should be
nice but I'm just saying yeah no I hear
you
for the final story Jason Momoa is going
to voice Frosty the Snowman in a
live-action picture for Warner Brothers
and Stampede ventures Warner Brothers
and Sanpete ventures have set up Frosty
the Snowman a live-action film that will
see Aquaman star Jason Momoa voicing the
iconic snowman thoughts here are my
thoughts on this I absolutely love Jason
Momoa like the hair the arms the eyes
everything the tattoos but I'm not gonna
be able to see any of that as a voice
character and while there are so many
things I love about Jason Momoa like his
voice is not really anything I ever
noticed so I most likely won't be seeing
this even though I am a stand amongst
stands um it's just like weird like some
people I get what I mean I get why any
solo have a face for animation ya know
but also I get why like major stars
transition into a voiceover work it's so
easy and it's so much money like and you
get to like reach a whole new audience I
totally get it to me this just seems
like a very strange move for Jason Momoa
like sex-symbol Frosty the Snowman
I don't normally put the two in the same
sentence um and I think Frosty the
Snowman is the sexy ha ha ha honestly me
too like those curves sexy it's just
weird
thank you for saying I should really do
like Jason was voiced though and so I
think he'll do
good job I don't know if I'll be
watching it just because I don't know if
it's like meant for me but I it's it's
some interesting news you know it's some
interesting news I'm so glad you brought
it up but it's just weird like unless
there's gonna be a side by side of like
him in like a steamy voice booth with
his shirt off I'm really not interested
in making this much he's gonna have some
arm you know where like unless there's
like a behind-the-scenes for real like
if i phi by the DVD and there's not some
special effects of Jason Momoa in like a
really warm small voice booth and the
can turn the air on
because of the microphone and he's
getting really warm and they just he
said can you mind if I take off my wife
Mike we don't say might be there anymore
sorry uh take top t my t-shirt and he
starts dabbing his like sweaty chest
with it
I will only purchase the DVD if I can
get promised that in the special effects
afterwards that that is a thing okay I
said what I said and I will I don't know
like I haven't watched a live act
actually I guess I watched live-action
films they're a really big deal they do
a pretty good job with them you know
yeah like beating the bees I haven't
seen one I didn't love Lion King right
so maybe this with maybe this is the
next one for us which it's a live-action
snowman how the [ __ ] do you do that
sorry H you know what my Matty and
snowman I'm really about to make a fool
of myself but like I'm not 100% sure
like what story Frosty the Snowman is
okay I know but I'm Jack Frost and he
makes the snowman in the snowman comes
to life and that's where the story kind
of ends for me I'm not sure like what
what what adventure do they go on okay
so according to the picture in this
article there's townspeople who look
excited behind frosty and frosty is the
Snowman okay Santa is in the air so it's
definitely miss miss miss miss Phil it's
a Christmas film I think I'm getting
excited rusty is marching with people
behind him and he's carrying a broom
is he a leader he's a leader since like
Jason mode voice him oh you know what
this whole thing is coming together
actually see each other see each other
from Khal Drogo to Frosty the Snowman
this is beautiful and
the song to Frosty the Snowman I'm a
duck duck duck down the lyrics you got
duck duck Duck Duck gonna that I like to
scat my Christmas songs I'm sorry
daddy that that dad and I was gonna yeah
yeah happy for Jason Aloha always know
before we let it burn a day in every way
before we let everyone go into the
holiday weekend we are excited to be
doing another segment today of Kelly's
mindless news like the fourth of July
this one actually doesn't come from
People magazine it comes from hello
which is also a magazine that loves to
write about her I believe they're big in
the UK and you're not gonna believe this
Jackie the headline is hit me the house
I was like earth-shattering okay Kelly
Ripa's porch Kelly Ripa's porch at home
in New York has to be seen to be
believed
Kelly Ripa has quite the eventful
lockdown and recently returned back to
New York following several weeks spent
in the Caribbean okay so we're
confirming yeah confirmed I like her
there just like there was a whole
article investigation a never liked gave
us the full circle moment and just like
put it subtly in the first line of the
next article
so Kelly to live with Kelly and Ryan
stars no doubt happened to be back so
happy to be back surrounded by home
comforts and recently shared a photo of
herself and Mark and swales posing on
their porch the spacious area features
wood paneled floorboards and a cream rug
giving it a homey feel
there are also coordinating wicker
chairs and a wooden side table making it
the perfect place to relax
Kelly shared a photo of them to showcase
their new cool cat hoodies by design oh
but by designer rocker veneering and
there's a picture of will obviously post
it on our Instagram see the picture just
it's blurry are you joking me it has an
ex-pro filter to be seen to be believed
no first of all it looks like a regular
porch like yes there is technically
wicker chairs and a cream carpet do you
see the cream carpet yes the cream
carbon and the wicker chairs could have
100% been for Mike home depot there's
nothing special about the wood paneling
yes it is in fact panels of wood that
you would see in any apartment in in the
world so this is not in New York City
and this is I could buy the shiplap on
the side of the house it's giving me
Hamptons vibe so now Kelly's in the
Hamptons right in the
Kelly yes like I just I know that we are
gonna be off for a few days and I want
to make sure before leaving for the
weekend
everyone knew exactly what was going on
in the world and I don't know if you
could really leave your house today
without knowing that Kelly's porch has
to be seen to be believed and I just saw
it and I don't believe I know it's
unbelievable it's unbelievable
and that's all she wrote anything you
want to promote before we cook off the
weekend I always want to promote the
redheads which I've already done
I also would like to promote my Jackie O
flow presets either so go this is gonna
be a great summer weekend head over to
Jackie O flow comm get yourself a pack
of presets my new favorite vibe this is
the past pastel path it's a pack of how
money it's a pack of seven for how many
dollars for thirty dollars well you know
other packs are five or six for $25 I
one time but a one preset for like $50
like people who price their presets like
that are insane that's a very good deal
thank you
so head over to Jackie O flow come get
your pictures on and pop in and tap me
fabulous thank you guys so much for an
amazing day and I hope you have a
fabulous weekend spent with loved ones
and happiness thank you so much for
listening to the morning toast
millennium morning show where we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube so if you're watching us
on YouTube please feel free to subscribe
give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found so that
Spotify iTunes stitcher Public Radio
iHeartRadio cashbox all the places so
ever you listen to podcast find us the
morning toast and leave a five star
review how about a beautiful stunning
and smart we are we love you guys very
much and we hope you have a fabulous day
happy 4th of July will see you on
Tuesday the 4th of July